voilà finale à suivre sur france 2 à
partir de 3h25 cette nuit littérature on
célèbre ce mois ci le cinquantenaire du
deuxième sexe de simone de beauvoir pour
m'en parler notre invité claudine montel
qui a signé les mémoires d'une jeune
fille rebelle simone de beauvoir le
mouvement des femmes alors bonsoir
madame vous ne vous êtes pas intéressé à
simone de beauvoir j'imagine par hasard
vous l'avait personnellement très bien
connu je les ai rencontrés à l'âge de 20
ans en 1970 c'est à dire deux ans après
1968 quand a été créé le mouvement de
libération des femmes et que
véritablement nous avons décidé de
prendre en main notre destin
c'était un choc pour moi j'avais 20 ans
elle en avait 62 et elle aurait pu être
ma grand-mère et core model
comment était un modèle pour gomis était
un modèle pour moi puisque ma mère avait
vu sa vie changer grâce à la publication
du deuxième sexe j'avais lu ses oeuvres
pendant mon adolescence et c'était un
rêve qui devenait réalité
la première fois que je suis arrivé chez
elle 1 dimanche après midi
je me suis assise près à l'écouté et ça
n'est pas du tout ce qui s'est passé
c'est elle qui a commencé à nous poser
des questions
alors vous me parliez de votre maman
qu'est ce que le deuxième sexe
précisément à changer dans la vie de
votre mère il a tout changé
ma mère voulait devenir chimiste faire
une carrière universitaire de
scientifiques en 1949 après la deuxième
guerre mondiale
il n'était quasiment pas question pour
une femme de faire de la recherche n'est
pas de très bons taux ce n'était pas de
bon ton seulement lorsqu'elle s'est
retrouvée enceinte de moi précisément en
1949 est paru le deuxième sexe elle l'a
lu et là sa vie a changé car elle ne
s'est plus senti seul et elle a su
qu'elle aurait la force maintenant à
présent pour se battre et pour devenir
chimie alors qu'a porté précisément le
deuxième sexe aux femmes de cette époque
là a montré que la femme était ce qu'on
peut dire un individu à part entière
absolument que la femme était un
individu à part entière qui avaient le
droit au même respect que les hommes qui
avaient le droit d'avoir son autonomie
et qui pouvait mener sur tout et choisir
la vie qu'elle entendait mener et en
particulier également le métier parce
qu'à l'époque un certain nombre de
métiers étaient uniquement réservé aux
hommes
il
sans culpabiliser en plus sans
culpabiliser et je crois que c'est ça le
mot le plus important pour le deuxième
sexe c'est qu'il a déculpabilisé des
milliers de femmes de par le monde et
que donc précisément il leur a donné une
force qui permet aux femmes d'accéder à
la vie qu'elle entendait mener
et vous personnellement vous étiez à
peine né je crois quand le livre est
sorti vous êtes une enfant de simone de
beauvoir il vous apporter quoi vous
alors il m'a apporté tout parce que
d'une certaine manière j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir une mère féministe et c'est une
grande chance parce que c'est une force
dans la vie mais en même temps j'ai pu
puiser moi aussi la force pour mener la
vie que j'avais envie de mener et faire
mes choix et être un être autonome en
lisant le deuxième seuil tout ce qu'il
faut de la force pour être une femme non
il faut de la force pour être un être
humain et mener la vie qu'on a envie de
mener je crois que l'on soit homme ou
femme
alors on se souvient très bien de cette
phrase de cet aphorisme on ne naît pas
femme on le devient
est ce que cela est encore vrai
aujourd'hui c'est totalement vrai je
crois que c'est d'une grande actualité
d'ailleurs de nombreuses femmes de par
le monde se remet à traduire le deuxième
sexe dans plusieurs langues
il est sorti en russie récemment il
vient encore de ressortir au japon dans
des versions intégrales et enfin la
ligue du droit des femmes lance un
concours pour les jeunes et pour les
livres les jeunes garçons et filles pour
les lycéens et des étudiants sur la
phrase on ne naît pas femme on le
devient
qu'est ce que cette phrase vous inspire
vu donc vous voyez c'est tout à fait
d'actualité mais on voit cet aphorisme
justement utile aujourd'hui toujours
moderne
on parle beaucoup de la parité en ce
moment que dirait simone de beauvoir sur
la parité pareil je crois que simone de
beauvoir dirais d'abord que rien n'est
jamais acquis et qu' il faut faire très
attention en cas de crise économique
dans toute situation difficile
immédiatement la situation des femmes
est en danger et je crois qu'elle serait
de toute manière très heureuse de voir
que les femmes veulent prendre leur
destin en main et ne pas se laisser
faire et surtout ce qu'elle a aimé aussi
avec nous avec l' aventure que nous
avons menées dans le mouvement de
libération des femmes c'est le fait que
nous voulions prendre notre main notre
vie en main tout de suite et ne pas
attendre dans un avenir hypothétique
qu'elles sont encore les batailles qui
restent à livrer je crois qu'il reste
beaucoup de batailles il reste beaucoup
de batailles sur le plan économique il
reste aussi des batailles de par le
monde
ce que la condition des femmes est
différente selon les pays et c'est une
bataille quotidienne et je crois que la
question politique dans le monde
économique et à leur autorité
je crois vous avez tout à fait raison
c'est bien les femmes accèdent un
certain nombre de métiers mais je ne
vois pas beaucoup de femmes pdg de
grandes entreprises et je ne vois pas
non plus encore de femme présidente de
la république mais peut-être cela
viendra t'il à jour peut-être peut-être
nous verrons tout reste à faire merci
claudine monteil je rappelle le titre de
votre ouvrage simone de beauvoir le
mouvement des femmes merci pour terminer
cette illustration en norvège de la
vague de froid qui frappe actuellement
l'europe du nord et en particulier la
scandinavie un journaliste s'est amusé à
jeter en l'air une casserole d'eau
chaude expériences spectaculaires pour
montrer qu'au contact de l'air froid et
bien l'eau chaude se transforme en glace
elle a fait passer en norvège ainsi
s'achève cette édition verte